system will reach critical mass sooner
than expected if we don't stop it now
all life on the island will be destroyed
leading the mission will be the finest
mech captain in all reality
shall be behind the controls you and
your team will be on weapons
the bridge is yours
paradigm
weapons team listen up
today we're going to put an end to the
imagined order
for good
our target is their weapon system
the collider
ground team status ground team standing
by
we'll have those shields down by the
time you reach the island
after all they do call me the legend
uh-huh probably that
stand by to engage launch sequence
[Music]
[Music]
crew to battle stations
[Music]
go
weapon systems hot now clear as a path
through those rocks
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
prepare for re-entry i'm taking her down
[Music]
we don't have much time to hit the
collider
clear a path i'll get us there
uh legend i thought you were on the case
yeah yeah yeah nothing we can't handle
just as soon as we figure it out
yep what he said
impact
divert power to heartbreaker
perfect strike
[Music]
we take
we're letting too many through
systems damaged
we're not going anywhere without repairs
don't worry i know a guy it's your time
to shine buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
it's worth a shot
[Music]
i can't believe this is working
really for the wind
are back online
the collider's charging up we gotta move
take them out
they've eliminated the shields
the colliders exposed
we're on our way
light blade activated
i'll take out the blimp
you focus on the ground forces
all enemy forces have been eliminated
this is our chance
divert power to blade strike
[Music]
fuel systems
can you hear me
anybody hurt
come on come on on your feet let's go
i don't think sloan's too happy we're
here i see
joe
and she has a tank so we gotta go
stay down and follow
me
fire from me forever
help me take out those cards
systems
[Music]
at the top of the collider everything
ends
the zero point shifting realities keep
your distance
unless you want to go wherever that
are is take a nap
incoming
teamwork
[Music]
60 climbing
come on come on
you just don't know when to quit
i finally get a chance to finish what i
started
yes
[Music]
[Music]
you don't have to do this
always so dramatic
any last words jones
um
look at him
i
thought you could use a hand
welcome back paradigm
[Music]
uh
who is that the zero point is focused on
geno
this is our best chance to find it
let's go
all right it's up to you now we don't
have much time those crystals will
detonate the zero point take them out
zero points almost to the top
one
that's it
don't worry i got you
[Music]
[Music]
you